what is the story but find behind your
character
professor poopy pants leather pants yes
don't be ashamed of it just embrace it
it's wonderful just professor poopy
pants it feels good so he is he's a he's
a Nobel winning a scientist who is made
fun of for his name poopy pants and he
then seeks vengeance on the world and
seeks to eradicate laughter and to get
his revenge which is kind of funny
because it's it's somewhat similar to
someone who is now the President of the
United States who was made fun of at the
White House Correspondents Dinner by
Obama and several years ago yeah at the
Meijer and I think that was sort of when
he decided that he was going to run for
president and eradicate laughter
ironically hopefully like poopy pants he
he inspired quite a bit of laughter and
poopy pants is an inventor and I think
our current president is an inventor as
well of luxurious stakes and quality
universities they both have amazing hair
I don't know if we have a pan yeah
there's a lot of yeah poopy pants has an
adventure size Raider where he can make
things bigger or smaller just like our
president claims to have very big things
and then has very small hail both say
well yeah we'll say you've got that
place your have gotten political now and
you go meet Conan you know banana have a
Bill Maher again and we don't have that
yeah love smoking weed
[Laughter]
you